das hier sind keine Pulled Pork Tacos
sondern Pult mushroom Tacos boah
wir brauchen mushrooms in dem Fall
Austernpilze dann Sojasauce Paprika
Cayenne Pfeffer Kreuzkümmel Knoblauch
und wir fangen an indem wir unsere Pilze
einfach in Fasern zupfen jetzt nehmen
wir uns eine ofenfeste Form und würzen
das ganze mit unseren Gewürzen
durchmischen und Öl dran geht es riecht
und sieht jetzt schon so ein bisschen
wie Pulled Pork aus aber wartet mal wenn
das aus dem Ofen kommt da geht's jetzt
aber erstmal rein für 20 Minuten bei 200
Grad und so sieht es aus wenn es aus dem
Ofen kommt guckt euch das mal an die
Hälfte des Volumens ist nur noch da und
ich sage euch so viel der Geschmack ist
dafür komprimiert das machen wir jetzt
noch eine schnelles heißer Koriander
Zwiebeln dazu eine Tomate
auf eine Knoblauchzehe und zu guter
letzt noch eine Chili bisschen Öl dran
und fertig ist unsere Salsa wir geben
die Tacos auf die planschaft jetzt
nehmen wir ein paar von unseren
mushrooms legen Sie auch unsere Tortilla
ab und etwas von unserer Seite in die
Mitte und für die mutigen noch ein
bisschen aus